the prophet said to us
do you think that this lady can throw
her son
in the fire alhamdulillah
[Music]
afghanistan
in about 20 minutes ramadan is about to
start promising another
blessed month for us to get closer to
allah wa tala
however this ramadan bronze says we're
going to be obviously as if ramadan
getting ready to prepare to eat to go
throughout the day
but brothers and sisters there are
people in somalia pakistan bangladesh
yemen and different parts of the world
brothers and sisters where they're not
going to have nothing to eat to break
their fast or to even have soho brothers
and sisters so i'm asking you guys to
help me to reach 300
000 meals but it says very easy just you
know the link at the beginning
that we showed it's in the description
box please go there and give what you
can shine let's reach our target
straight into this video this video
for every parent out there it is the
worst nightmare that you could ever have
i'm going to play this video this short
we're doing chava and in this video
brother and sisters
a disturbing thing of a baby choking
and i want you to pay close attention to
the reaction of the mom and the father
and you would understand why they behave
like that
because one day you're going to be
parents let's watch
i think at this moment i think he is
well
wow wow wow i think he just saved the
baby
she's four months old he
he literally saved her wow
she was choking and this is very
interesting because i heard that this
doctor was actually
so tired on that day and he was going to
go home but for some reason
he stayed there yeah he stayed there and
brothers and sisters look at this look
at look at
the look at the father and the mother
the father's literally kissing the guy's
feet like he's literally on the floor
on the floor look at their reaction
brothers and sisters
you know it reminds me of a saying my
mom used to say to me yeah
and subhanallah well as as as as a
father
you know as parents that are watching
this all you guys future parents
you do not know the horrors of ianni to
even
fathom to think something's going to
happen to your child and sisters so much
so subparanal album since i lost final
title fruits
told us that there are jannah for those
who lose children promises that is how
um severe it is now brothers and sisters
handle this
this child was safe here that is not
surprising to me
that that father behaving like there's
not surprising to me at all and you know
what
two things come to my mind bro and
sisters yeah and narrated by abu
hurairah allah
i heard allah's apostle saying allah
divided mercy into 100 parts and he kept
his 99 pounds with him
and sent down his one part on earth and
because of that it's one single part
his creations are merciful to each other
so that seven
so that even the man lifts up its hooves
away from the baby animal
lest it should trample on it that's the
mercy allah save more of it in the
hereafter but this very hadith is
amazing
and for every single one of you guys
watching this whoever some people call
you guys ramadan muslims or whatever it
may be
this is a specific message for you guys
mom and sisters
this shows look how merciful they are to
their children you saw how they are the
cow was on the floor they were they were
in a state of shock because of the mercy
they have to their child fear of them
choking to their hand allah may allah
preserve
their children and allah save them
listen carefully for you guys for you
guys in ramadan starting for us all of
our sinning i will get closer to allah
this ramadan
make sure you make the most of it you
know why here's allah's mercy and this
how much allah loves you
loves you guys said
sam sabi a war prisoner children and
woman only
uh were brought before the prophet uh
and behold a woman
amongst them was milking her breast to
feed whenever she found a child amongst
the captives
she took it over her chest and nursed it
she had lost her
child but she later found him yeah the
prophet said to us
do you think that this lady can throw
her son
in the fire we replied no
if she has the power not to uh not to
throw in the fire of course not
the prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam
said this listen carefully allah
is more merciful to his slaves than this
lady to her son
what i'm gonna end the video on this i'm
gonna be along with you what does that
tell you
that tells you brothers and sisters that
allah loves you guys
and allah wants gender for you he's
given 99
paths of mercy one mercy in this life
and in 98 for the hero of the most
merciful
yeah we recite this in the quran al
hamdu lillah
[Music]
brothers and sisters from the beginning
recite yes
allah subhanahu wa allah the most
merciful the very merciful
yes allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is most
merciful and he wants you
the best for you guys just as this
church there's just these parents want
the best for their child i was about to
choke
allah wants jannah for you use this
ramadan to get closer i don't care if
you fall into sin
get it make your intention this is a new
beginning let's do this inshallah
and best way to start this off with
provinces if you have the means even if
it's one pound
feed the the donation that we have here
promises to feed 300 300 thousand meals
this ramadan sadaka this way in the way
of calamity
give inshallah and let's have a new
beginning to ramadan assalamu alaikum